People ask me all the time,
"What is the toughest part
about growing up
in the foster care system?"
I was an 11-month-old baby
when I was placed in foster care.
By the time I was in the third grade
and I was about nine, I was adopted.
I was given a new forever family,
but it was far from a loving home.
I was consistently
referred to as the N-word.
The refrigerator couldn’t be touched.
She cared more about that check
than she did me.
By the time I was 15, I was sick of it.
I knew that I needed
to take matters into my own hands.
So after watching
"Law and Order," the show --
(Laughter)
Thank God for Olivia Benson.
I realized something.
I needed to get the evidence
of what was happening to me.
So I took a recorder and I took some tape
and I taped that recorder to my chest
and I got the evidence that I needed
to get back into the foster care system.
Even without abuse,
foster care is a tough experience.
You don't know what's actually
going to happen to you.
You're placed with a stranger
and you're expected to become family.
But if you don't fit in,
if you act up a little bit too much,
you will find yourself in a new home
with new school,
new rules, new everything.
When I was placed back
in foster care at 15,
I thought that that
was the end of my storm.
But it was just the beginning
of the next storm.
I didn’t go back home,
went to a few different homes,
but unlike many,
I was placed in a non-profit program
where I got ready to live on my own.
The foster care system is not doing
a good job of raising children.
Unsupported foster youth
are two to three times more likely
to have negative outcomes
related to homelessness, incarceration,
being sexually trafficked.
The mental toll is severe.
I want you to think about war veterans.
Foster youth are two times
more likely than war veterans
to experience and suffer from PTSD.
This is why I started Think of Us,
because this is the current result
of the foster care system.
It's designed wrong.
So we approach problems differently.
We actually engage those who are impacted.
We ask questions, we listen.
We take the collective experience
of thousands of people
who are impacted
and turn that into data and insights
that then we know what are the most
broken pieces of the system
and where we can start to redesign it.
We work with leaders
across the entire sector,
people with lived experience,
to co-design new solutions.
And then we do whatever it takes
to implement those solutions.
I want to give you an example.
We overwhelmingly heard
from teenage foster youth
that they were being misplaced
in group homes.
The system was acting like
they have nowhere to place these children.
Turned around,
we sent our researchers out.
And what they were able to reveal
was that the majority of those children
actually had extended family members
that they could have lived with.
On top of that,
that they were having these
very traumatic experiences.
We collected those voices
and lifted them up.
The vibration of the truth
of what they shared with us
was so strong that it helped
inform litigation
brought on by the United States
Department of Justice,
the Civil Rights Division.
It helped inform an investigation
into institutional abuse
by these for-profit group homes
by the United States Senate.
It helped inform an amicus brief
that went to the United States
Supreme Court.
That is the power of lived experience.
The key to transformation
is lived experience.
For the past eight years,
we've listened to thousands
of young people.
And it's become so clear that there's one
key thing that we need to transform.
And that is who children
in foster care get to live with.
Kin.
We believe that kin can transform
the foster care experience.
Kinship care is when a child goes ahead
and is able to live
with an extended family member
or an adult that they have already known,
an adult who loves them.
That adult can be a church member,
a close family friend.
And what we now know
is that research is showing
that when children are placed with kin,
they fare way better,
from mental health, to stability,
to graduating high school on time.
And yet only 35 percent of young people
in the foster care system
are actually placed with kin.
But it doesn't have to be this way.
In one state, in partnership, right,
we went in and we implemented
some simple solutions,
like, let's ask young people which adults
in their family they should live with.
(Laughter)
I wish I told you something better.
That is one solution.
(Laughter)
We ask,
we went ahead and like, require
social workers to get extra approvals
if they're going to place you
outside of kin.
The result?
The initial placement with young people
in the foster care system
in a situation where
they were living with kin,
rose from three percent
to over 40 percent in just two years.
(Applause)
In another state, we looked at a county,
we looked at that state, and in one county
they were able to figure out
how to place over 80 percent
of those children with kin.
So the idea that young people
don't have adults in their life
who can step up, is not true.
Here's what this shows.
That when the system believes
that children should be raised in family,
guess what?
That the children are actually
raised in family.
For me, I was almost 30 years old
when my sister called me
while I was visiting New York City.
She told me that in just three hours
that my father's side of the family
was going to be having a family reunion.
They didn't know I existed.
And I didn't know that they existed.
And so I raced over to Harlem,
walked through that park,
looking at every single family,
wondering which one was mine.
When I finally arrived,
words can't describe that moment.
They were kind.
They were accepting.
They were curious about who I was.
And then about 90 minutes in,
everything changed.
I discovered that I had
four aunts and uncles
who had been fostering
longer than I had been alive.
In that moment, all I can do
was go into my pocket,
pull out my phone,
open Google Maps
and GPS to my last foster home.
Fifty-eight miles away.
My whole life,
I was always 58 miles
and a couple questions away
from being raised by people
who could have loved me,
by people who could have been my family.
The worst part about this
is that my story is actually not unique.
That every single year hundreds
of thousands of children
are entering the foster care system
and they're not being placed with family.
And again, it actually
doesn't have to be this way.
The system spends over 30 billion dollars
on less than one million families a year.
That is more than enough to make sure
we find family, we support them,
and that every child is living
in a loving family situation.
Right now,
there's a big systems change opportunity,
a federal decision
that would make it super easy
to have people who are related
to a child step up and say,
"I'm willing to do this"
and get that support.
If approved,
we would see three billion dollars
shift from traditional foster care
to kinship care.
So when we work on these crazy ideas
like “let’s make kinship care the norm,”
it is actually possible.
And I want to leave you
with three things to think about.
Number one, I came on this stage
with, like, a very simple idea.
Children should be raised in family.
How can we replace the majority
of foster care with kinship care?
Number two.
How do we center those
who have been impacted,
those who have lived experience,
in making kinship care the new norm
as we design it and implement it?
And the last part,
I want to tell you,
we need some help.
We need some allies.
We need you to become advocates with us.
And you don't have to be
a foster care expert
to know the power of family
and to know that every child should
be being raised by family
or someone that they know
when it's possible.
I will say this.
I truly believe we're at this pivot point.
And then if we push just a little
bit harder in this very moment,
that we can actually live in a new reality
where when children have to come
into the foster care system,
that the first thing that is looked at
is extended family,
it's people that they know.
And if we are able to achieve that,
we will literally be able to ensure
that millions of children
will come off of that school bus,
go into their homes,
look at family members,
people that they know,
and say, "I am loved."
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)